you know the difference between the  button and us versus russia  did you have you seen that article  okay so you know in us the button is  controlled by who  president one person  he can't push the button there he needs  multiple multiple approvals in russia  so russia's situation is not like what'd  you say boom that's u.s that's not what  it is in russia  so that gives a little bit of comfort to  say you have to convince three or five  people whatever the amount of people is  for them to say we agree that it's time  to push the button so  i think for the world that's a little  bit worried it's good that russia's  button to the nuclear bomb is a lot more  regulated believe it or not as weird as  it sounds  than the button in us